>> Dan: THE SABRES ON THE GET A
HERE EARLY. YOU GIVE THE
GOALTENDER A LITTLE FEEL.
ZONE.
PLAYED UP THE WALLLL
PLAY HERE DOWN THE ZONE. THE
BETTER IN HIS OWN ZONE. CHASE T
FAR SIDE AND A NICE PLAY
>> DT ATTEMPTCK.
PAD SAVE BYACCENT ON IT THAT HE
ON TO IT..S DOWN THE LEFT SIDE..
>> Rob: THEY'RE GOING BOTH WAYS
HERE.
IT'S VERY PHYSICAL.
EAKIN.
GOOD NUMBERS BY BUFFALO TRYING
HE WILL TAKE THIS TO THE FRONT
OF THE NET, G
ZONE.
JUST LEFT THAT PUCK IN
TOKARSKI WITH ANOTHER SAVE. IT K
TO THE CENTER LINE. DUSTIN
KOHARSKI.
HE STAYED WITH HIM AND LOOKS
LIKE HER.UT MAYBE GET
THAT UGLY ONE TO CHANGE THE
MOMENTUM. CORNER.
PYSYK T T THE SABRES AND UP.
THE QUICK SHOT.
PETERSEN MAKES THE SASA
ANDREAS ATHANASIOU WITH JUST ON
FOR DINNER.
AND IT'S AT 4:30 SO THEY HAVE
SHORT-HANDED.
IN THE SLOT, TAKES THE
GOAL.
LIZOTTE COMES UP WITH ITITIKE B.
FITZGERALD TRYING TO KEEP THE
PLAY IN THE L.A. ZONE. KINGS AS
GET TO CENTER.
IAFALLO PLAYS IT FOR ATHANASIOU.
.
IT WAS A 1-0 GAME.